so all of this has brought us to the 10%
point of the movie about 10 minutes in
the movie altogether is about 2 hours
and 10 minutes long if you take away the
credits so it's very close to 120 130
minutes so let's just rough it out and
say it's 120 minutes long and we'll
divide the percentages by that so
somewhere around the 10% would be around
page 12 at page 10 or or a 10-minute at
the 10-minute mark
kaffir egos and is assigned this new
case he's got to defend these guys who
are accused of this crime down at one
time obey and then right at 12 minutes
he goes and reports to Galloway this is
what I termed the opportunity of the
movie it is the first new thing that has
happened to the hero everything we've
seen up to this point is and must be the
everyday life the hero is living and has
been living for some time he's a hotshot
attorney he hasn't been in the Navy very
long he's very cynical he doesn't really
care he doesn't follow the rules much
but this is who he's been for some time
but now there's this new event and that
is he's assigned this case he moves into
now stage 2 what I call a new situation
someplace the hero has never been and
during this new situation he has to
figure out okay what is going on in this
new world I've created it's a it's a
period of questioning it's a period of
figuring out what is expected of me here
what am I gonna do what is my goal in
this situation how am I going to go
about doing that he's gonna gradually
formulate the goal that will drive
through the story and start formulating
a plan for it but all of these next
scenes are about him figuring this out
so he goes to Galloway and he gets more
information about the the Marines who've
been accused and then they have this
banter and she's very critical very
disappointed because he's yeah you know
he's never been in a courtroom she can
tell he doesn't care he's very cynical
and so on he goes into this meeting with
Weinberg who is his best
friend and also has just been assigned
to this we'll come back to the
characters of Galloway and Weinberg in
just a little while because they both
are what I call reflection characters
but these two stages on this outer
journey level take us up to the
one-quarter mark the end of Act one and
at the end of Act one at the twenty five
percent mark it actually happens right
at the thirty five minute mark if you're
watching the video this they are going
to leave for one tana MoBay so it's no
longer about figuring out what they have
to do what he has to do is he has to
defend and try to get either an
acquittal or what his initial goal is a
reduced sentence for these two guys who
are accused of murder or accused of
murdering this other marine by
strangling him in his bed so that's
basically stage one and stage two as far
as the outer journey are concerned
you